be myself be yourself staying be
yourself I am Who I am be myself if you
try to pay something that you are not
then it's not gonna work for long how
could you do this you want to be you
that's what it's all about
I said look why why don't we change
everything up is a boost me be myself
just me
Jack you change that takes a lot of
confidence yeah I believe it also I
really thank you you know the producer
will see you he said okay do whatever
you like to do
yeah change no boost in harmony when
Bruce Lee Ching hai I kick love when
Bruce Lee after punch I do know just
like normal human being normal when I
was young I'm fighting on the street one
by one
oh my knock somebody down to buy one up
somebody down three I'd run away so in
the movie do the same thing
I just everything used in the movie
Youth it's my real life I think it's
good again it goes back to a bit of a
war me saying as well like in the
discipline as well the discipline to not
get caught up in the moment
you know music is like stocks to you
know there's the hot thing of the moment
you know there's this hot electro sound
or the hot auto-tuned voice or the hot
whatever whatever it's new and exciting
and you know you know people tend to
make emotional decisions based on that
you don't stick with what they know this
is who I am this is what you know this
is what I do and then they you know jump
on this next hot thing and you know it's
it's not for you so for me just having a
discipline and having the confidence
that that and Who I am you know and if I
go into a studio and if I find my truth
of the moment there's there there are a
number of people in the world that can
relate to what I'm saying and and it's
gonna buy into what I'm doing you know
not because it's the new thing at a
moment but because it's my genuine
emotions is how I feel this out I
articulate the world and you know just
having to discipline it just you know
yourself yeah I guess my advice for
young performances just just do you like
there's seven billion people in this
world and there was no one like you and
there's no one he's gonna write songs
like you know and he's gonna sing like
you as long as you keep it exactly
yourself I mean imitate people to a
point to get your inputs and kind of
help you write songs and help you along
is how I help you sing but once you
found your voice just do that and stick
with it and even if it sounds like it's
old and people are telling you it won't
work just stick with it and eventually
it will because there's seven billion
people in the world there's bound to be
one person that likes a music man you
just gotta stay true to yourself you
know never try to follow the trends
that's when you get lost in the sauce
man you got it do what you feel man and
be creative and don't be scared to be
yourself and always keep that faith you
know I've been in the darkest times of
my life man where I didn't know what was
gonna happen and I was flat broke
anything you could think of man I've
been through it and like you know you
got to be strong enough to make it
through and it just makes it that much
sweeter when everything starts going
right Steve wasn't original and I don't
think there's another one of those being
made and so I've never really viewed or
felt the weight of trying to be Steve
it's just it's not who I am and it's not
my goal in life you know I am Who I am
and that's that I'm focused on that and
being a great CEO about all what did I
learn from the youth of 11 million
people I learned every youth wants to be
unique every youth wants to be unique
that is you the over you to are to be
unique that is you but the world around
us around you is doing its best day
night
you just be everybody else now now the
question is whether you want to be you
or everybody else you you want to be you
not everybody else now
if the coach be like everybody else is
convenient and the first class but not
satisfying in the long vision the
challenge there for my young friends is
that you have to fight the hardest
battle you have to fight the hardest
battle which any human being can ever
imagine
to fight and never stop fighting until
you arrive at your destiny I just think
that people it's it's pointless for
people to get into a creative arena and
say I want to be the best I mean you
know there are everyone has what they
have they'd say what they say and you
could never compare you know Picasso
with Lachey I mean you have to everybody
has something different to say and it's
silly to get in there and say my brush
stroke is better than another person you
know it's better to say am i being true
to myself and is this what I want to say
and have I expressed myself you know the
way I want to express myself yeah I mean
that's what it's all about
if you try to be something that you are
not then
not gonna work for long very well
I mean I don't think you will enjoy your
life if you just try to make other
people have been
do what do you finish the right thing
for yourself I'm fans of athletes from
all different sports I've never tried to
emulate anything else I tried to be
myself I've learned a lot from watching
guys you know especially guys when I was
younger but I think in terms of
leadership I think leadership is viewed
differently by different people I mean
there's there's people that lead by
example people that are local leaders
people that do a little bit of both I
think you just have to be who you are I
had a job out of college working for a
bank for a short period of time Mellon
Bank and I um decided to well first it
might have been ink magazine this is way
back when but there was an article about
using changing something in how you
deduct social how you save Social
Security from employees paychecks and
literally hadn't been working there for
three weeks and so I send it to the CEO
of Mellon Bank hey I thought you might
be interested this literally some guy he
never heard of and I got no effect said
thank you nothing and okay you look my
whole job my whole motive in taking a
job working for somebody was to help
them become more profitable that's the
way I always looked at it and then I
started a rookies Club where I reached
out to some executives and all the
people who had started at the same time
at Mellon Bank we don't go out and get a
drink and we'd get this executive start
and I didn't like run it through my boss
or anything and so my boss at the time
calls me in and said you're doing this
is I said yeah I think he's gonna say
great it's just her screaming at me and
Rhema Meade how could you do this you go
everything through me you work for me
yeah so I knew I wasn't destined there
and then I left and I went down to UM
ended up down in Dallas and got a job
working for a company called your
business software and we were we sold
software and and I didn't know anything
about software I took one computer class
at Indiana and kind of cheated to pass
but not that I condone that but
and so I had a customer and I thought
might stay up all night teach reading I
think you know computers were new and
technology was new this technology was
new so nobody had a head start on me
because it was changing so rapidly like
it is today that if I just put it in the
time I can learn as much as anybody else
and so I taught myself I'd stay up late
reading software manuals taught myself
different little simple programming
languages and kept them getting bigger
and bigger and better and better but it
was at a retail store and one of my
responsibilities was to come in sweep
the floor wipe down the windows and open
the store and I had a customer who
wanted me to come out there and close
the deal and it was a fifteen thousand
dollar deal fifteen hundred dollar
commission to me told my boss he said no
you need to be there to open the store
and I made the executive decision that I
was gonna go get the check because you
know I was living six guys in the
three-bedroom apartment sleeping on the
floor and this check meant I could like
not use the same holiday in towels with
holes in them that I'd stolen you know
but anyway so I went and picked up the
check thank you when I came back and
gave the check to my boss all would be
forgiven and you know the sales cures
all fired me fired me and so those
back-to-back experiences confirmed what
I already knew that that I was just
employee and then I better start my
rings thank you so much for watching
please let us know which one of the clip
that you liked the most
leave the comment below thank you for
watching you need to believe and we'll
see you soon